[Music]
it was like 30 pounds of rice you could
probably make a cheesecake with one of
these this is the shrimp Mountain it's
only crazy if it doesn't work whoa this
is huge
okay that's like 40 pounds one two three
whoa
hey guys I'm Alvin and I love making
giant food
we're back with tasties making you big
season 2 everything's bigger and better
than before who's gonna be a big asset
is big I'm probably gonna be a little
bit bigger by the end of the show but
I'm very excited to show you guys the
giant food and the special guests we
have for this season today I've invited
in honey eggs a popular book bomb
artists on YouTube who better to make
giant food for than someone who's used
to eating giant portions so let's go
meet her and see what she wants to eat
how are you good yeah what are you
hungry hungry good well I'm a big fan of
yours and you are a very popular artist
on YouTube right where you upload videos
of you eating giant amounts of food what
is that called it's called mukbang and
it's derived from the word London which
means eating and pungsong broadcast and
it originated in South Korea why do you
think people enjoy watching other people
eat it's interesting to listen to other
people's life stories while they're
eating and sharing their love for food I
really want to cook for you today and I
want to make something giant that you
like to eat is there any food that you
would love for me to make today I would
love to see a giant version of a sushi
roll okay it's funny that is the number
one requested food I always get it's
just like please make a giant sushi roll
please make a giant sushi roll you're
really good at what you do on your
channel I've always been very curious
about like doing mcbomb could you teach
me how to do it later if I can make the
giant boat for you yes of course I would
love to teach okay well I'm very excited
for that so I'm gonna get to work and I
will see you in a bit all right bye
okay we're gonna make a lot of sushi I
want to clarify before we get started
this is 100% American sushi this is not
Japanese machine you have a lot of rice
here yeah we rinsed out and to cook
sushi rice we're going to dump this into
a very big pot okay with a lot of water
let's just do that well that's cool my
grandpa used to say you got to eat every
grain of rice out of your bowl because
if you don't every single grain of rice
is one hairdos he's also bald so I'm not
sure why he told me that so we're gonna
cover this with a lot of water this is
going to be brought to a boil then I'm
gonna cover it and simmer it on low for
20 minutes and gonna have a lot of sushi
rice after that alright it's been about
20 minutes this rice should be cooked by
now so we're gonna take a look and see
how it is whoa that's a lot of rice all
right I want to fluff this rice okay
it's a lot harder and a lot hotter than
it seems
steam is hot you guys be careful okay so
I'm gonna try to get all this rice out
of the pot into a bowl let me see how
okay that's kind of heavy I might have
to call some help so I'm gonna go get
Ryan one of our amazing culinary people
all right guys this is my buddy Ryan
he's one of our amazing food people you
got it Brian's very strong this is why
he's doing it okay how's your day going
Ryan you know this is gonna be the
highlight is it giant red did you go to
the gym yet no they think this is my
workout I don't need to oh thanks right
yeah appreciate it hi this is like 25 30
pounds of rice all this cools down I'm
going to make the sushi vinegar mixture
to mix with this rice so first long when
I give myself a steam bath I'll be right
back
the rice is cooling we're gonna make our
version of a sushi vinegar mixture for
our rice gotta go in with the rice
vinegar followed by the sugar salt and
the vegetable oil so there's a lot of
rice and a lot of weights and the reason
we're adding vegetable oil is to help it
hopefully not stick too much together
because I think you'll be adding a lot
of pressure on the rice it could cause
the granules to burst and just could
cause the whole thing to clump together
too much okay this is the cold rice this
vinegar mixture is hot it's ready to go
we're gonna put it into the rice so it
absorbs better than if it were cold oh I
shouldn't have done that over the rice
don't do this if you're about to go on a
date afterwards we have a nice little
paddle to mix this rice in so the goal
of this you want to coat as many grains
of the rice as you can ideally every
single grain of rice is coated with the
vinegar mixture but it's a lot of rice
I'm not an expert this so I think this
is a pretty much there I did my best and
my arms might fall off afterwards so
we're gonna call it do you want to taste
it though oh I actually have never made
a sushi roll before so I want to
practice doing a normal tissue as I
don't want to mess up the big one so we
have our sushi mat the saran wrap is
gonna help make sure that it has an easy
release from the roll we're gonna take
nori which is seaweed the shiny side
stays down because the shiny side is
what's gonna be on the outside of the
roll a little bit of the sushi rice this
is pretty fun actually then we're gonna
go with our toppings so we're gonna go
down with a piece of cucumber over here
followed up with some cream cheese and
then on top of that a smoked salmon
that's looking pretty good for fillings
so the rolling what we want to do is
kind of use the mat as a guide to roll
it without having to get your hand super
into it
okay that looks pretty good actually
it's clean stroke so it's actually not a
half-bad Alvin I want to take a picture
of it this is my first ever sushi roll I
think I'm ready and we're gonna go make
the big one so Cheers
we have a giant sushi man this is an
invention made by our culinary team who
really helped me out because I asked
them for a bamboo curtain we could not
find a bamboo curtain to roll the sushi
so they stitched together six regular
sushi mats you know really big for this
one don't get stuck to yourself do not
dare get stuck to yourself I'm thinking
we can go like make like a giant square
this whole thing is 18 inches I do want
some space on the side so minus one inch
on the sizes even seven and a half
I'm just gonna do it hold up one okay
cool
and then we're gonna try to seal the
edges of the nori with water so it's
kind of like dumplings where if you add
water to this side it will get sticky
and hopefully stick together do this
boom okay so we have kind of a square
let's get rolling
okay you're just gonna press it down and
flat okay so this is ready for toppings
let me get to it so let me see these
cucumbers start here time for the cream
cheese you got bigger blocks this time
they're huge you could probably make a
cheesecake with one of these this
hopefully it doesn't fall apart all
right now for the smoked salmon this is
like a couple pounds trying to keep this
pile together here we're going big and
we're not going home
Wow okay that's a lot of stuff I might
have overfilled it but we're gonna try
to roll it okay this is the
nerve-racking part I'm kind of getting
flashbacks to the 100 egg omelette I
made and we're gonna try to roll this
car a lot of tucking going on so you can
go up I'm gonna need it tuck it keep it
tight now and keep it tight gotta keep
it taste so it won't fall out okay let's
let's do that for now
it's like give me this guy like a little
massage I think that's a roll we get it
ooh whoa this is huge like the size of a
baby I'm gonna name you Herbert hey
Herbert you're a fat baby
we're gonna wrap up Herbert and it's
blanket and throw them in the fridge
until he gets nice and cold and hard and
ready to be cut
sleep well Herbert cool this is roll
number two because this is an inverted
roll that means the rice is going to go
down first that is a lot of rice my
strategy is to do the the harder things
on the bottom so we're gonna go in with
the cucumber first and then we're gonna
top it with the crab this is imitation
crabmeat I've heard it's some sort of
blend of fish but fooled me we're going
with the avocado this is also kind of
scary because the there is no nori on
the bottom it's just the rice and
there's a lot of stuff in it whoa that
was close
all right Alvin don't do that again lift
from the bottom and then slowly slowly
no come on why is a problem child gonna
press it down and bring him back Shum
blues boss I'm your father I'll call you
Theodore he's the most devious of the
three chipmunks whoa
I'm gonna finish by garnishing it with
some sesame cuz I think it's just a nice
touch
Theodore is done
moving on to roll number three we got
shrimp avocado and cucumber so it's just
can't ride to it feel like I'm getting
faster at this as I move along so that's
a good sign
I'm really into the shrimp where they
taste like almost good shrimp okay yeah
it's actually kind of looking precarious
I want to stop right there this is the
shrimp Mountain elevation four trips I
put too much ice oh wait that's coming
apart the shrimp mountains there's an
avalanche okay cool that's fine that's
okay we're gonna touch oh oh yeah look
at that that's pretty cool if you guys
have been to the restaurants there are
rules that have these patterns on top
when they kind of have these different
names apparently there's a roll called
the caterpillar roll because there's
like avocados fanned out and I really
want to try that out to see if I can do
it probably not gonna do this right
that's like kind of it wanna see if we
can put that on there okay that's a lot
of avocado thing is on in order to get
it to form to the shape of the roll you
have to take this top and then just like
press it down hard you need it to almost
bind to the rice all right well this is
the one with the shrimp I love it it's
my favorite I'm gonna name this one
after my dad cause he's pretty cool so
it's not Peter wow I've never been able
to have control over my dad like that
what a change okay
rule number four we got again cucumbers
cream cheese that's next time
Carmy it's pretty much set nice another
roll that's pretty popular in the
restaurants they have salmon on top
can't really go get sushi grade salmon
in such a large quantity Costco
unfortunately didn't have it so we're
gonna go with smoked salmon perfect it's
like as if these things were designed
for giant rolls made by an Asian guy
that doesn't know how to make sushi oh
yes okay that was cool Wow look at that
that's like exactly what it looks like
at the restaurants when they do the
salmon roll I gotta give this guy name
really good-looking on top and call this
guy Brad Pitt so our wonderful art
department got us a beautiful wooden
boat to serve the sushi on I think it's
amazing I think it looks better than a
plate okay we're gonna unroll Herbert
he's been sleeping for a bit Wow look at
that that's so cool
we're gonna put this on let's go Brad
Pitt I've seen videos where they cut the
rolls with stuff on top and they cut it
in the saran wrap so it's easier to hold
the top together look at that that's so
sick all right so this is roll number
three the problem child the avocado okay
I can never hit tire these
cross-sections and I've gotta lie look
at all that shrimp each of these has
like a little like like a green
comb-over like a double comb-over
airdrop all right I have one more roll
this boat is at full capacity we're
gonna capsize if we keep going so I'm
just gonna cut it up and then let put it
on a nice little rectangle plate
okay so I cut up the last one it's
nicely plated because it won't fit on
this okay that's like 40 it's like 40
pounds and the last finishing touches
just a little bit of pickled ginger
clean your palate a little bit tiny
little squeeze of wasabi all right so
this is pretty much done it looks really
cool I'm very happy with the way it
turned out
and I'm excited for honey to eat it so
I'm gonna go bring her in all right
welcome back yeah yeah
the sushi is in front of you so on three
one two three
is your sushi this is a regular sushi
roll for scale this is actually my first
sushi roll have ever made there's some
spicy mayo and some soy sauce for
dipping time to learn how to do McClung
properly so we're gonna get some chairs
sit down and you're gonna teach me
okay honey we're in a different sort of
setup can you explain to me why things
are set up this way so this is set up a
lot in front of us because it looks
bigger this way and you want to show our
viewers everything so we have it set up
all around us so I haven't intro it goes
hello my honey bees it's your girl Kenny
and so you're gonna go it's your boy oh
hello my honey bees it's your girl honey
it's your boy Alvin and today we're
gonna be eating 40 pounds of sushi rolls
Celeste again cuz they're so hungry you
have an intro my intro is just like I'm
Alvin I like giant food first buy a
purse but you guys eat first and for me
I do this thing called honey bite which
is like your biggest bite you can take
okay so let's try that and three-county
bite I'm also gonna drizzle some spicy
mayo of my sushi roll and then I go
drizzle drizzle drizzle drizzle drizzle
drizzle drizzle drizzle drizzle ah and
have like the most sauce on my food
that's a lot of sauce this is like one
of the craziest things I've ever eaten
I think so are you last bite
[Music]
yes you there well we're gonna probably
keep you eating for the next how long
would you take to finish this finish
this maybe like 40 minutes to an hour
kidding me thank you for teaching me how
to do look fun properly thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't hit that subscribe button if you
haven't already and to become a honey
bee and I'll see you guys in my next
video
am I getting so tired already it's fun
oh it's so cool this is about a 40
pounds worth of stuff it's like so many
different textures in here I don't think
this is doing anything but it's fun oh
wow
Wow
[Music]
welcome back to Tasty's making it big
this is the show where I make giant food
for my friends and special guests today
I've invited in Kalin Ali you guys might
have seen his vile reactions to release
really awesome food videos and I'm
really excited because I've always
wanted to see he'd react if I cook for
him so let's go meet him
okay well hello hello what's going on
are ya good big fan oh well thank you
very much I know a lot of people out
there probably know what you're famous
for but in case some people don't what
do you do so essentially my main job is
I react to food videos how did you get
into this like where did it all start
I was on my way to work and I was like
Lena my BAE and I was going through and
it was actually a tasty video came up
and it was a dis corn bread and I was
like oh I should make a video to this
and I put up my phone press record and a
real history I've definitely learned a
lot from watching you react to other
people's videos I've definitely been
more cautious about the way I approach
the stuff that I make and I would love
to cook for you today and make you
something really really giant what sorts
of foods are you into I am into a lot of
food that I love I love Italian as well
okay yeah are there any dishes that you
think maybe you would like to request
for me to make I mean the doors wide
open
spaghetti Oh like spaghetti meatballs
are just spaghetti spaghetti meatballs
okay so that means a meeting like giant
spaghetti and giant meatballs I actually
liked it a lot of people get mad about
it
I like sugar in my spaghetti Oh
interesting I like my spaghetti to be
sweet I want to get working on the food
but I might call you back in you know
cuz I would love to see you react
real-time to some of the stuff near the
end because that's where all the food's
coming together so I'll get to work and
then I'll call you back for some
reactions later okay
okay we're gonna make some Giants we're
gonna get meatballs in giant spaghetti
meatballs the first thing as well the
spaghetti so we're gonna start with
fresh pasta we're gonna go in with eight
cups of flour and some salts and then
we're gonna mix this together with a
fork to evenly incorporate the salt with
the flour this is eight cups of flour
it's actually a quarter of the total
batch because we if you do it all at
once it'll be kind of crazy so the
amount of dough we're making here seems
like a lot and that's only one fourth of
the whole thing so that's pretty cool
so once the flour and the salt are mixed
you want to go in make kind of like a
little well like you do after you get
the well we're going in with the eggs
this is a dozen eggs that's twelve and
we have a little bit of water to also
help this come together you don't really
want to go in to mix everything you kind
of want to like whisk all this all these
eggs and water and get it into a nice
mixture first so that it's more evenly
incorporated that's why we made well the
whole entire pasta batch for Kalin's
Giants getting meatballs is going to be
32 cups of flour and 48 eggs also known
as a lot of stuff it's like a yellow
whirlpool am i getting so tired already
it doesn't all have to come together in
the bowl you just need to get it to
consistency where you can dump it out
and also I just want to stop doing this
so we're gonna dump this out and
continue to knead that goal is to kind
of shimmy it into a workable dough yeah
this is its own unique workout if you
make pasta from scratch every day we're
gonna be really jacked in like one arm
and then the great thing is that this is
also your spun in shoes so you can just
do this it's been about ten minutes and
I think the reason why you have to kind
of go for so long is because it's a
pretty large portion of dough it really
worked the gluten you got to get all the
liquid from the egg all the fat and the
egg to really combine with the flour but
it's looking pretty good now
this one says looking cold it's been
about an hour I have made a total of
four giant pasta dough balls and they've
all been resting at room temperature for
at least thirty minutes this is the one
I most recently made her name is
Gertrude and we're gonna cut Gertrude
into 16 pieces to roll through this
pasta machine go straight down the
middle
oh yeah eight look at that sixteen
totally not even pasta triangles and
we're gonna get this into a sort of like
a rectangular shape a little bit of
flour want to turn on our pasta machine
right now it's at the thickest setting
this is a one setting and because it's
on a stand mixer the stand mixer is
going to do a lot of the work for me
which is nice enough to do myself
all right the stand mixer is also on the
lowest power setting so it isn't just
like shoot out pasta everywhere
are we gonna do that a couple of times
so he can get it to be a little thinner
it's so nice having someone else do the
rolling out for me I just kind of hold
it and caress it and let it go so that
looks pretty good it's gotten a lot
longer than we started at this point
we're gonna go to the second setting cuz
if you go from one to like three too
fast it'll like bottleneck in here and
it's gonna be a big traffic jam and
nobody's gonna be coming out smooth
everybody's we pissed
they're like Swan Lake should be playing
right now
all right 15 worker Trude pieces to go
so now that they're rolled into these
long sheets I do want to cut them into
really wide and big noodles I got a
really cool toy this is a pasta bike
kind of like an accordion it almost be
like an old-school torture device oh
[Music]
it's so cool we have essentially is
really really nice pasta noodles like
that this is one noodle it's like it's
like 2 feet long that's awesome you in
pressure even pressure all the way
through nice I think that's why they
call it a pasta bite it literally feels
like you're riding a bike through a
field of pasta that's kind of a dream
this is Gertrude now reborn into a
almost like flower like Picasso painting
but this is only one of the four dough
babies that I have to get there so I'm
gonna go put this in the back and I'm
gonna go ride my bike for another hour
or so so uh I have to make giant
meatball I'm not really sure how if you
just make a ball that big and you bake
it it'll like kind of flatten in the
oven and I really want a nice like
spherical kind of shape so I'm gonna try
to search up Giants you her ball yeah
they're all like sphere moles large ball
bowls for cocktails like 3 inch 4 inch
I'm not that's not good okay okay so
apparently there's like these cake pans
that are like hemispheres that
apparently they use for like those dome
shaped cakes they say sports cake pans
I'm assuming it's like those cakes where
it's like a soccer ball a basketball a
big one that's how they make those and I
think if I can actually get two of them
I could potentially put meats and like
and like a big sandwich and then
bacon oh there's like a there's like a
specialty Bake Shoppe a couple couple
miles I put my eggs in one basket and
hope that they have it so I'm gonna go
shopping and I'm gonna go get those
bolts
well I found these at the store
these are nice big hemisphere molds I
told the guy that I was gonna be making
meatballs and he was like yeah we used
those for cakes and I was like hey
Meghan King put some sheets in crimp it
around the edge and we use this guy to
press it down make a nice little shape
all right let's try to make things nice
and even hear that nice me both vessel
we have 27 pounds of ground beef and
this is gonna make for meatballs we have
48 eggs have a lot of Parmesan cheese we
have 12 cups of bread crumbs fun facts
every four slices of bread is 1 cup of
bread crumbs so we just threw it in 48
slices of bread and with the amount of
eggs we just put in here plus the amount
we used in the pasta this is close to
100 eggs 2 onions Italian seasoning salt
garlic powder and pepper this is about
I'm gonna say 40 pounds worth of stuff
what's in a wild it's like so many
different textures in here don't really
want to talk about it an average
meatball is around 1 ounce so 27 pounds
of ground beef is equivalent to 400 and
32 ounces of beef so these 4 die meat
balls will be the size of 432 meatballs
like punching it
I don't think this is doing anything but
it's fun the goal here is to make sure
that we don't have any lumps or pockets
or clumps of any of those individual
ingredients I want to get all this into
one homogeneous mass so we're gonna be
here for a long time we're ready to put
the mixture inside of those foil balls
but we do need to spray those molds
first because you don't want the mistake
this mixer makes for meatballs and this
is one meatball so I'm gonna try to
divide this up into like a quarter and
try to compress it I kind of want this
to also come above the lip of the
meatball because me it's gonna shrink in
the oven and if you cook it and it's
below it'll this like dirt and then
it'll become smaller and we'll be fine
before Sarge the meats into the quarters
okay let's just do this and we're gonna
squeeze hard it's like a meat sandwich
kind of looks like Piranha Plants that
was one I want to make three more use up
the rest of this bad boy over here and
we're gonna bake them all off for a very
very long time until they're cooked and
pray that they retain their sphere shape
it's been about three hours the
meatballs are almost ready they look
crazy there's like four giant Death Star
things in there we're just trying to
time it so that by the time the
meatballs come out the noodles are
coming out so we're gonna boil the
noodles we got but the first thing that
we have to do is we have to obviously
salt the pasta water so go here it's
really hot we're gonna go in with these
noodles go in here okay
so because this is fresh pasta it cooks
very quickly but these are thicker
noodles so we're gonna cook them for
about four to five minutes hopefully
we'll have some delicious bouncy al
dente thick pasta noodles okay so these
are pretty much ready big spatulas big
spider we got whoa that's pretty awesome
okay they're going here when I throw
some oil on it so they don't stick and
then just to taste
mmm we're really good it's a great first
batch we're gonna go with a second one
here I think is to keep the water going
in a vortex as the noodles go in so that
it don't stick all right second batch is
ready it's coming out nice and bouncy
and springy hit it with some oil
just like the Gordon Ramsay olive oil in
perfect please don't be mad Gordon mmm
I'm gonna go cook
like 20 more though them a little bigger
all right cool welcome to the sack Kayla
thank you doing I'm exciting you hungry
I'm very hungry what do you think of all
this stuff we got some okay
so I noticed that those aren't spaghetti
noodles aren't those what are those
called pin it started peed on it let's
start with the P Papa de Leon something
like that
hey I think that sort of thing on the
menus Papa deli Papa deli
yeah I mean we cut them and you know we
made them by hand and then we just like
cut them really long with the power I'm
gonna start by putting down the pasta
noodle okay
now where you gonna need to go pants bro
I don't know our department got them
from the hardware store they may or may
not be pants now when you bought them
noodles do you see these in the water
I'm seizing the water okay cuz boasters
be throwing it up in the water and bling
and noodles that knock you how many eggs
do you think it took to make this uh
this batch of pasta you know what I've
never made fresh pasta before so I'm a
guest I'm gonna say 15 48 48 eggs a lot
of chickens huh oh yeah it was busy how
long you been cooking I've been cooking
since I was in high school did you go to
culinary school no not at all did I
learn to cook you know nein yeah my mom
taught me over speakerphone while she
was in China yeah you should really yell
at me and told me what to buy
so this is our nest of pasta noodles I
can tell
it's making a nice landing zone for the
meatballs beautiful
that is impressive they look like
planning you know you can take those
together and put that in somebody's
solar system for a science fair project
oh wow oh wow wow oh quad well great
color to them - yeah there's a good sear
on it right uh-huh uh-huh
Wow is juicy - Wow this is insane
we got the sauce here beautiful for your
request there's a little bit of sugar in
here oh thank you so you want to taste
it that's perfection where you get a
ladle they'd be a same restaurant supply
store I don't know but it smells like
the super Style section it's the area 51
section yeah here you go oh wow I was
like a volcano smoke it's hot and really
baby how many tomatoes I don't know I
think the whole farm how do you feel
about this amount of sauce I think it
looks great
all right cool cuz we're not done yet we
got a garnish it oh okay what we're
garnishing we got some cheese a man now
listen when I go to Olive Garden I'm
always a person you know when they be
like will tell me we play we be sitting
for five minutes
giggling go ahead garnish that thing
with that cheese you all won
yeah anyone else order some good cheese
oh yeah people in there on you all right
I got you how do you feel about parsley
little you know I think less is more
the taste of the person food oh yeah a
lesson definitely more with this parsley
Jesus almost took me out a little bit
definitely okay this is it we can eat
now however you think this is I would
guess this to be probably around fifty
pounds
yeah that's there that's heavy okay
heavy that's real heavy okay you ready
to eat I'm ready
all right what would you like to start
with first but I feel like we need to
plate it again yeah so we need to grab
some noodles first down okay okay she's
crazy comin here this little crevice
right here yeah we did give me some
sauce look at that see oh I was like
tableside prime rib mm-hmm no good here
you go sir thank you some cable side
meatballs Alec thank you so much just
cut myself a slice of meatball nobody
ever says that yeah cuz they don't have
to yeah
all right Cheers you outdid yourself at
this one hmm
this best damn me behind they ever had
its moist
you would think you know with that big
not dry it's not dry then he's not at
all
I mean it's seasoned very well thank you
if there's a lot of flavor in there
how many'd you to open up a restaurant
own a giant food that's it and you know
it's LA so all the instagramers to go
crazy because then going to take
pictures or put a big big pink wall yeah
sorry that's all you need
go big or go home okay mm-hmm my posture
still got a little bit of bounce to it
mm-hmm
it's not overcooked ain't that crazy
now people who like an ounce of bouncing
and overcooking you know made all this
possible you need this perfect well
thank you they make Tupperware just be
it I only get my Tupperware this way we
can go to Bed Bath & Beyond to find a
bathtub
oh don't work thank you so much for
coming today thank you for coming
I'm glad you like it feel free to keep
on eating okay but see you guys next
time bye y'all I'm staying
[Music]
Oh God I messed up everything it shows
over we're done that's like 30 pounds of
s'mores right here welcome back to
tasties making a big this is the show
where I make giant food for my friends
and special guests today I've invited in
Quinta Brunson you might know her from
BuzzFeed videos from her show hair flick
and from her HBO series a black lady
sketch show she's super awesome and I
really want to see if I can impress her
with a giant version of something so
let's go meet her so Quinta good well I
know that a lot of people are excited to
see you here today they've probably been
following you you know watching all the
stuff you did at BuzzFeed I do want to
know though what is your relationship
with food uh so I love to eat it I don't
think that's unique cooking it frightens
me terrifies me I have this fear of
killing people I'm just now starting to
get over it I'm starting to cook a lot
more and experiment with it but that
fear is still there I mean cooking I
will say it can be dangerous it can be
dangerous and then it has to taste good
after all of that I kind of wish that
people went in judge food if it didn't
taste good like I went through a lot of
work if it didn't taste good just live
with it I don't know if you know I've
actually been challenged by a fellow
tasty producer name's re8 she wanted a
giant marshmallow but I was like why
don't we take that one step further and
I wanted to see if I can make a giant
s'mores okay that sound okay man cooking
for me I don't care what
get to work okay all right sounds good
see Quintin well this is Rhea
you probably already know her she's the
host and producer out make it fancy
she's been on wertha she's been eating
your feed is pretty much taking over
Internet so I'm very honored to have you
on the show
yeah but you do say best oh I heard you
talk a little smack I in some of your
previous videos I love to I wish it was
my pillow
I wish album make it big for me you know
I can't really back down from a
challenge like that so we're gonna make
a giant s'mores today what's the first
step we gonna make giant graham cracker
mmm I've made a gram [ __ ] out before I
can everybody giant Oh we'll see okay
first we gonna mix dry ingredients okay
all-purpose flour whole wheat and sugar
cinnamon baking powder
good job thank you I'll mix this and
you'll work on the wet ingredients yes
so canola oil honey how does this look
to you so pretty good yeah so I'm going
to fall over so it's like a construction
one why is it like construction work
have you made of cement before no I
think we might have to use our hand okay
all right gloves on boss is so sad like
what sand
whoa he's getting tougher
oh my god no this how you get your mouth
off Shh
I think I need to go to the gym more
just like to be ready for this very soon
my whoa
oh I don't think that's we put those
things away
you need a likes a quitter you're doing
like like mochi Oh like a treat
[Music]
okay so is this good yeah yeah right
alright we're gonna take this into the
fridge so it can rest all right bye-bye
well I mean I made this guy in the back
well this guy was hanging out so what do
we have to do so we are going to roll it
all and are we gonna use two parchment
paper
as a guide basically I want to make this
sighs it's tricky yeah you need
something else to help you I need some
elves yeah but why does it have to be
Elvis I don't know what you did in your
own you're a pastry chef yeah I hire you
Heights and pelvis 500 Mills laid off so
this is pretty good do you want to get
into the tray now yes
all right think we have to help each
other off oh yeah that's what best
friends do right yeah yes sorry ready 1
2 3 go
nice
right I think it looks good yeah it
looks nicer than mine
thank you yeah okay so now the signature
thing about the graham crackers are the
holes what's our strategy we're gonna
use giant Fork and you want to do it
first I can follow you yes you're cool
so what are the holes do it prevents
expanding too much so that's a puffed-up
okay cool
combined ray and I have created 1200
holes let's go bake these graham
crackers Oh baked out really well it
smells great I think it's time to make a
giant marshmallow I want to borrow a
technique that I used in my 100 layer
those anya video where you make walls
out of foil and you reinforce them with
dry lasagna noodles I think we'll use
maybe like seven by four lasagna noodles
huh you can lay these about like a
centimeter apart what we're gonna do is
we're gonna fold it across you press
this flat and you can see all right one
two three four five six seven so this is
where we break it it'll make the pole so
it's like this this is way bigger than
I've ever done it so it's kind of crazy
this is DIY engineering okay oh yeah
let's do that and then we'll just go
around I guess like a snake and then
BOOM tada okay we're gonna make a giant
marshmallow yes let's start with some
gelatin okay followed by some water get
it with this whisk attachment you also
have to make like a hot sugar make sure
that we can whip later so let's turn on
these about high heat
I like how synchronized we are corn
syrup then let's both water yeah
vanilla let's give this a stir so we're
adding sugar and corn syrup because you
know when you're working with sugar
temperatures very important I'm sure
you'd know that so you can take it you
know like five degrees up five degrees
down and suddenly the texture totally
changes so the course here was almost
like a safety net or like it doesn't
immediately go crazy let's turn on these
mixers and make some marshmallow yeah
all right so we can go slow
this is very hot sugar please don't try
this at home I think we were going to
take a scoop of this and slowly stream
it into this wall it is going what's the
difference between making a fresh
homemade marshmallow
and just like eating the ones you eat of
the package I feel like it's tastier I
feel like it's less sugary and I feel
like it's more Airy yeah
the sugar is at 240 so it's at the
softball stage so by whipping air into
it you're doing thousands of little air
bubbles that cause the fluffiness of a
marshmallow and you're also cooling it
so that the sugar sets that it makes
sure that the marshal gets its bouncy
sort of texture so we turn it up a bit
all the sugar is in it smells amazing
transformations crazy I know just want
to squeeze it yeah so these are ready
turn off turn it up okay so let's get
these out okay on three we're gonna pour
into here okay one two three
like doggy-paddling it what's next
oh so next well we got to get this big
ball into our big wall situation we have
back there oh my god okay spray the
walls of the marshmallows and stick
mmm-hmm oh sorry sorry
ready three two one
the walls are holding all right Wow
[Laughter]
sorry Adam I'll clean it up right now
Adams pissed oh god I messed up
everything it shows over we're done
so that ported really nice powdered
sugar
you know marshmallows you coated in
powdered sugar so they don't stick when
you cut them yeah make it rain
you're doing great this looks amazing I
just can't wait to cut into it okay so
this it's really hot sugar and I think
we need to let it cool around coupie
beep so we're gonna make a giant
chocolate bar yeah what kind of setup is
this so we are boiling the water and we
are going to put bulb over melt
chocolate sure and so it's like a slower
more even heat than okay first we gonna
use like half over the chocolate chip
okay and then I'm adding coconut oil huh
so this is like a pop it's eight pounds
so each chocolate chip weighs about one
gram or less and there are 454 grams in
a pound so eight pounds of chocolate is
3632 chocolate chips if this giant
chocolate bar that we're making your
true age oh yeah I'm not really helping
the stereotype
how about I hold this while you do your
stuff yeah sure I want you to use both
because it's metal Rea is concern for my
safety
don't I am dumb at what she is my best
friend there's no emotion with that line
the chocolates melted so
weeds out of the other bowl like Willy
Wonka
really won't well your Willy Wonka
that sounds about right oh yeah what's
next are you gonna pull over so we can
wait giant chocolate bar all right let's
do it
get in there okay you can do it okay
thank you hold Yuri a said I can do it
here we go
[Music]
almost got it over the side I'm just
gonna hold the bowl here gonna scoop out
and if you miss any I'll just eat the
rest don't worry about it okay just look
at the ball all right
oh we doing that I was a hot joking
I wasn't look Wow beautiful and you
magically got no chocolate look at your
apron look at mine I have flour sugar
and chocolate all over my apron Rhea is
looking hey I'm a fancy lady that you
are very insulated effort to set into
chocolate bar with the cool it right yes
let's try two together see guys time to
assemble we have two fully baked graham
crackers cooled a marshmallow that's
inside the walls and a really really
nice solid chocolate bar can we just
like kind of flip it onto it you know if
that works you want to give me some
moral support okay that'd be great
follow me yeah okay cool nice oh it's
good firm crust snow so there's a lot of
extra sugar maybe we brushed that this
way first you know when I was in New
York
oh my favorite things to do what after
snow I'll make snow snowman but instead
of making face
oh just print your face create tsunami
look like yeah we get Queen that we
should plan our faces at but I'll think
of something
Oh what's gone okay whoa oh that's so
cool mochi yeah hmm that's glad so
what's next okay well you requested a
giant marshmallow and so do you have a
special present yeah yeah give me one
second yeah I got the culinary team to
make you another marshmallow yes because
I know how much you wanted to use it as
a giant pillow so how about I hold it up
and you can lay your head against it
it's like a memory foam farm back to
business
thank you I think we'll just get in here
okay yeah let's try just get out okay
get dirty we're just gonna transport it
over okay yeah and then go go go go go
okay it's coming out what's the best
part about a s'mores reate poaching
fortune fire yeah I'm gonna wash our
hands we're gonna get to the fun hey
high five
I ready for this crash and burn baby
whoo I'm using to blow torches every a
is using an attachment called the Sears
all time Omar's getting course you have
a secret message decreed that she may be
jolly got hearts yeah
that's pretty much it I think we did a
great job yeah okay so the chocolate
goes on next right yeah how do we do no
no it's okay let's bring it over here
and see slide that out don't break don't
break don't break yeah okay and then
we're gonna go down right there yeah Wow
nice the final layer we have to put on
the cracker don't break it
I just think I have some special tools
that'll make this possible one second
sorry a what is a pizza peel all right
over there and then you let go
[Music]
great job that's my god yeah I was wild
that's like 30 pounds of s'mores right
here Wow
I feel exhausted I think it looks
amazing yeah I think the proportions are
correct the chocolate is melted the
marshmallows toasted and it's actually
really want to eat it but we have to go
get Quinta first yes keep going keep
going keep going
well Quinto we have a giant s'mores okay
in front of you so on the count of three
open your eyes one two three it's just
silly yeah they're regular thing right
you know we'll get out don't worry this
is worth my weight it is more this is
ridiculous how we also have some big
milk for you baby
oh my god Danny how should we oh you
guys are all that thank you good this is
like I think it's the chocolate your
fingers yes ma'am sure sure I don't know
how to
oh it's a lot to handle
so the practicality of eating this is
not very high as you can see listen you
take a workout class today but I'm doing
this instead yeah thank you my mother is
gonna reach through the screens badly
about you right now we're gonna share
this with all the employees waiting
downstairs
thank you for coming on the show thank
you for having me yeah I appreciate it
chocolate wave I did it I'm very happy
with the way it turned out like
physically and how I look and how he
built it but probably not the most
practical thing that brings her
Christmas party if you want to press a
lot of guests I would say yeah thank you
for make my dream come true of course
anytime and thank you for helping me
make your dream come true great job
really yeah and if you guys want us to
make any more giant fruits together
you'll let us know till next time
oh wow this one this one's really fun
it takes her whole body to need together
we have 96 slices of cheese on the
scroll cheese we gonna play with fire
[Music]
welcome back to making big this is the
show where I make giant food from my
friends and special guests I've always
wanted to make a giant grilled cheese no
one's asked me to do it but I love
cheese poles and I've been really
inspired by this channel called healthy
junk food they've mastered the art of
making these crazy giant foods I thought
it'd be fun to invite them in to see if
they maybe judge one of my creations so
let's go meet them how are you thanks
for coming in just for the people who
might not know who you guys are what do
you guys do my name is Julia and this is
JP we're JP and Julia and we started
healthy junk food back in 2013 to try to
actually be healthier we started just
doing copycat recipes of like Big Macs
and contract Supremes making a healthier
and then we're like hey let's make it
bigger I like the way you think you guys
have made several amazing giant grilled
cheese videos one of the trickiest
things about making a giant goals
cheese's you gotta get that ultimate
cheese pull so when I get to that point
I might ask you guys to come you know
come and help me out because I've never
done it before and I really think your
expertise would help me make that cheese
pull really awesome that knew I'm good
with that
as long as you have to me a soup and you
could be dipping it in there so you guys
feel free to hang out and chill out I'm
gonna go work in the kitchen and we'll
go from there see you guys here for ya
for ya room for ya go 18 for Alvin yes
okay we're gonna make giant grilled
cheese and the first step in giant
grilled cheese is giant bread so we're
gonna take nine cups of warm water this
will help make sure that the yeast is
nice and activated not too hot it also
it'll kill it
oil salt sugar woof and yeast and just
gonna mix this together until all of the
sugar and the salt and the yeast is kind
of like dissolved in the water these
tool kind of incorporate and start
growing all right that's looking pretty
good
next step is ten cups of flour a lot of
flour but we're gonna do this in batches
- this is only half of it trying to make
sure there's no huge lumps welcome to
ASMR with Alvin this is about half of
the flour and we're gonna add the second
half this is a total of around like 40
cups will help her this is gonna Nate
make enough bread for the whole entire
dough
okay so it's coming together we're gonna
turn it out onto the table finish
kneading whoo boy bench flour
whoa LeBron James LeBron James LeBron
James there we go oh that was a bad idea
it's gonna start needing this guy oh
we're gonna need a lot of love her
this looks like a job of the hunt oh
okay this is the dough we'll call him my
bread baby and this is enough dough for
both slices of bread the grilled cheese
so we're actually gonna divide him in
half
mmm that's cool all right there he goes
awesome so we have two dough balls each
one will make one slice of bread for the
grilled cheese you will need to prove
for 30 minutes so I'm gonna cover them
and wait for them to grow up in size we
have a lot of time while the bread
proofs so we're gonna make a tomato soup
because you can't have a giant gold
cheese without a lot of tomato soup
we're gonna go on with a good amount of
olive oil as Gordon Ramsay likes to say
we're gonna throw in some vegetables so
we have garlic have celery and we've
onions oh it smells great so we're gonna
add some salt to tastes pepper and
tomato paste and this has to be cooked
out a bit can I spread this around fry
it up a bit
it's very tomatoey getting a tomato
steam face bath
well let's cook down a bit caramelizing
real nice so now I think it's ready to
put in the liquid ingredients
we're going with the crushed tomatoes we
have 8 28 ounce cans of tomatoes 224
ounces of tomatoes total then 6 quarts
of vegetable broth whoo-hoo and also
some nice fresh basil I love this stuff
always sniff your basil before you
hidden your food guys it doesn't change
anything about the food but it makes you
feel better we're gonna bring this to a
boil and I'll see you guys in a bit
it's been 30 minutes this is looking
amazing so at this point we have a lot
of tomatoes in here that's a lot of
acidity so you we want to add some
baking soda it's basic like a couple of
my friends and it's gonna help balance
and counteract that acidity from the
tomatoes okay so it's been simmering for
a while it's gonna mellow it out a bit
now we're gonna play with it this is
probably one of my favorite weapons of
mass destruction in the kitchen it is a
immersion blender whoo we're gonna be
blending and puree
all those vegetables we added in earlier
some of the crushed Tomatoes some of the
basil this is so good pretty good
obviously you gotta add some heavy cream
this is not Daiya food but it's freakin
amazing so we're gonna go for it all
those beautiful streaks just start
coming to the surface oh that's good
well we made three gallons of creamy
tomato soup to go along with the grilled
cheese we're gonna take this to the back
and continue making our giant grilled
cheese
okay so our dough has been proofing for
roughly an hour these will be the size
of each bread slice because it's the
largest pan that we can fit in a tasty
oven come on
okay it's ringing with our fingertips
spread these out to the corners of the
tray in this process we're also knocking
out a little bit of the air that had
come from the bacteria farts during the
proofing section all righty
that's one let's move this off to here
number two come on whoa that's awesome
I'll never get tired of that whoo oh wow
this one's this one's really fun trying
to get a lot of the air out of this cool
well this one looks great these two are
going to proof for another 30 minutes do
their final rise before we get them into
the oven
these have been proofing for about 30
minutes they got a little bigger in size
it's gotten a lot smoother and shinier
and basically these are ready for the
oven we're gonna bake two giant slices
of bread
[Music]
[Music]
we have some pretty awesome bread slices
right now one thing I think that's
important about grilled cheese is that
it is made with slices of bread not the
ends of the bread so that means both
sides do not have a crust on them all
right get in here mister
[Music]
whoa this is so cool since both sides of
these need to be trimmed I have an idea
that I think will make it look like it
is trim so we're gonna go with a
microplane it sort of grade off the
crust of the bread to make some bread
crumbs oh it's working
oh yeah strategy worked out nicely cuz I
think if I went in with a knife on both
sides
I'm not amazing at knife skills that
might have just destroyed the bread and
made it like not usable at all but it's
looking pretty good okay so I've been
chisel away at this thing for quite a
while so yeah this is looking pretty
good this is our bottom slice kind of
has a little well into it like a little
bread well with little bread walls so
that the cheese will not escape we have
four beautiful and amazing cheese's we
have mozzarella cheddar American and
Marty so we'll start with cheddar and
then we'll go with mozzarella so
American and some hearty look at that
for fit perfectly
I'm gonna build a grid here four kinds
of cheeses we have 24 rows of cheese
each row has four cheeses in it so we
have ninety ninety six slices of cheese
on this grilled cheese
okay so we're gonna brush this with
butter a lot of melted butter a lot of
bread so you need a lot of butter we're
gonna put like two sticks of butter on
this guy it's a lot but hey it's gonna
be great
and if you're eating grilled cheese I
don't think you're worried too much
about that content anyways okay so this
is the really really fun part we're
gonna play with fire this is a cool tool
that spreads out the flame over a larger
area because it's kind of hard to get
this bread into a pan that's big enough
to toast so we're gonna use fire instead
and I like playing with it so
[Music]
okay so I've been here for about like 30
minutes just seeing this build cheese it
smells great the butter the bread it's
browning we're making brown butter
basically this looks really good we're
getting a really nice crust and we're
gonna actually take this guy this is a
beautiful display of cheese 96 slices
and we're going to put it in the oven so
I'll see you guys in a bit guys look at
this looks so awesome it's like a
checkerboard full of cheese I'm super
excited that it kept its shape okay it's
going together real nicely we're gonna
put it back in the oven or like 20
minutes or so off we go
and whew this is a heavy grilled cheese
oh my god all right this is the final
baked grilled cheese it's been in the
oven for a total of 45 minutes the top
and the bottom are thoroughly heated
it's crispy
it's crackly if you can hear we have
these giant pits appeals that we're
gonna try to use to get this on to the
board that's one come on here we go
[Music]
nice I'm about to cut it but the thing
is this is a pretty tricky part and I
don't want to mess it up so I'm gonna
call in the experts
JP Julia you want to come in and help me
out I'm here to help you all then thank
you how's it going good that's bigger
than ours
oh I thought yours is like super huge no
I'm proud okay there we go
oh my goodness we're in come on Alvin
come on Alvin you have beautiful hands
thank you put concealer on them
sometimes one nice long stroke through
to make sure we're even
so the strategy I think we should try to
get our hands underneath to try to
support as much of it along the seam as
possible like this actually
so maybe Julie if you want to get this
area just like a little cheese baby one
[Music]
that was crazy he's me heard you guys
wanted tomato soup oh my goodness
oh yeah mamacita hurt yourself there I'm
gonna get a Sunnah excuse me oh no oh
you guys do not mess around the flavor
this is flavor tell see you got a little
one and you got a giant one okay yeah I
think you have a little something on
your face
Julie can help me do you want to take
that one home uh-huh next time thank you
well it's fun I got to live out my dream
of making a giant grilled cheese who
better than JP and Julia to judge if it
was awesome it sounded like they are
pretty impressed with what we were able
to make today that was awesome and
here's the thing if you guys have any
ideas of giant foods that you would like
to see us make on this show let me give
a comment tell us what you want to see
send me a message we do read them but
until next time
[Music]
this is dedicated to Keanu Reeves
all 100 layers are
[Music]
literally making it big yes we aren't
that is the name of the show I know I
just got excited
[Music]
welcome back to making a big the show
where I make giant food for my friends
and special guests today I haven't
invited Kelsey and Peach okay she's done
some cool stuff on buzzy multiplayer you
might have seen her 100 baby challenge
it's really crazy and I thought it kind
of fun to invite her in dream of a giant
food challenge we could do together so
let's go meet her so Kelsey yeah oh well
I hope you're hungry today you do a lot
of crazy things on the internet and one
of them is this 100 baby challenge yeah
so it's a challenge in The Sims where
you have a matriarch who's like one
character and she's supposed to have 100
different children with all different
parents you have to have a different
parent for every kid okay is she tired
she don't okay well we're on our second
matriarch now Shar our first one has
sadly passed off oh my god so you know
how you said every single parent it has
to be different that gives me an idea
because you know how there's something
like a 7-layer dip right you see where
I'm going with this what if we did a 100
layer dip where every single layer was
different I see where you're going with
this it's gonna be a challenge to even
think of all the ingredients if I do it
I will probably have to ask for your
help if you're down to like help me out
cuz I would think it's like you know
it's almost like a game you know we're
gonna have to figure out there's a
strategy to it I've been training for
this day alright good well I'm gonna go
brainstorm maybe with the tasty team and
then I'll go shopping and I'll see in
like half a day but yeah hi Kelsey
I need to make a 100 layer dip and I
need help thinking about all the 100
ingredients no sweets this is kind of
like savory tex-mex Southwestern so if
you have any ideas feel free to start
yelling I'm Alex okay so yeah Oh
chorizo that's really hard
oh yeah yeah that's a different that
counts that common ingredients burritos
Cheetos Lay's I need more cheese really
unfortunately no that's kind of gross
okay no okay I need one more can't end
on weenies guys I'm gonna go to the
grocery store and I'll be back in about
six hours so Oh God
whoo guys I got the stuff it's not like
four hours in there
someone help me want the door to my car
Thanks
[Music]
we got all 100 ingredients oh man no
we're gonna cook all these things and
build this dip don't know what's gonna
happen but I'll see you guys back in the
studio so Kelsey is that what we're
putting it in we went to the pet store
wood we got an aquarium oh I have a
little game plan here this is a color
coded order from top to bottom of all
the ingredients they are sorted by a
category there's gonna be a narrative
story arc throughout this dip you get me
I love a narrative story arc all right
ready yeah all right let's do it
editor put the snapping sound effect
yeah we're ready to go we have spoons
and utensils to get all this food into
here okay this is the breakfast burrito
section what is the very first thing
we're putting in first up is potato
chips if you crush them so they get like
crashing like so they get more
compresses as a hundred later that's a
good point
that's 199 more to go corn chips yes all
right let's go
that was nice amazing
oh now we have cheese I'm a very cheesy
girl normally start with Gruyere yeah
Gouda that's really yes it's about the
next breakfast sausage oh you're cute
spicy Italian sausage and you're Italian
right yes so it's just like me that's
what you were expecting to me no but
then again I like have simulated babies
as my job so
we're both we're both in a weird world
now we are okay what do we got
it's I can't pronounce that Oh awesome
kielbasa
it looks cool I kind of want to taste
one - oh I'm very sure let me shake it
yes a one for this time zombie ground
beef I guess for meat
yellow bell pepper Oh vegetables I like
vegetables wow that is really pretty
nice I'm so glad I have someone helping
I reduce sometimes means on the show
food and talking to an audience that
hopefully is watching that how you doing
slow guys thanks for watching see you
bye the end make sure to stay through
the whole thing so we just finished our
breakfast burrito next up is chicken
salad so we begin with a layer of
romaine roommates like one of my
favorite salads because it's so crunchy
crunchy right here you go your crunchy
my crunchy lettuce that's so you did a
really good job with the order here I
played around the Google Docs chicken
next how many chickens do you think that
is in this are you actually let's not do
that's kind of dark are you really
looking you're the one making a hundred
babies yeah someone doesn't make it
there seems there since okay there no
you watch black mirror don't you tell me
no I don't watch me I'm here for this
exact reason this isn't where it might
get a little messy so we have chicken
salad I think using hands might be a
little weird maybe we got a spoon oh yes
a rubber spatula aha all right you do
the honors you're doing a great job
spraying in here thank you I'm really
trying to put my heart and soul into the
spreading you're also putting your arm
into it yeah I don't know if I have
really had much chicken salad in my life
me neither it's not like a CT ur choice
when you get sandwiches you know it's
like on there but no one really wants
good Wow way to make those chicken salad
stands well upset
we got tomatoes tomatoes you're
beautiful you're like Keanu Reeves like
how he feels you're breathtaking
breathtaking this is dedicated to Keanu
Reeves all 100
corn corn all right avocado yes how do
you think we could buy with this how
many houses yeah none we live in
California next is Parmesan to finish
off our chicken salad you want to make
it right what are you first layer now
we're going to move on to a little bit
more healthy salad cuz this have got a
lot of cheese so what's first on the
list iceberg lettuce amazing ooh this is
my one of my least favorite lettuce
I hate this this one tastes like water
yep next up green cabbage cabbage is a
little better cabbage yeah kravitch I
like crap why do they call it red
cabbage it's purple carrots radishes
radishes you're gonna do like there's
like coins you can like make em rain
this is me at like the Barcade ma'am
this is the Chuckie Cheese
yeah red pepper hummus this is possibly
the best hummus I'll just do like this
technique the the scoop and poop I think
we can smear the hummus is together okay
oh my oh my oh my
hold on me finish gloopy okay I'll let
you poop sorry that was too cuz I hit
there whoops
Oh mrs. done Jesus goat cheese goat
cheese and feta cheese feta wait
thanks all yours
oh yeah good all right let's go whoo all
right next is cilantro
uh-huh it's launched about people panic
I like cilantro it tastes like soap to
me I tell people it's genetic they don't
believe me come on do it for the viewers
exactly I feel like it's like when you
feel a little kid like yeah let it go
oh man that's gross a little bit it's
it's just like so tastes like ass mm-hmm
not good all right well Mexico I love
you converse yeah why don't you take a
little cleanse that palate hmm cool
we're at layer 31 we got through the
healthy salad I think it's time to bring
in the next wave of ingredients yeah
probably gonna get a lot more unhealthy
from here on we're done bean and cheese
Lin let's do those beans yeah here we go
so black beans pinto and red oh yeah oh
that's a lot next refried beans oh just
I think it's like the previous three why
do they call the refried I'll look this
up later
yep someone knows and that someone isn't
on this set right now after that we're
gonna do
a type of cheese which one is that ox
occur Oh Oaxaca like like Mario cheese
let's go cotija cheese where do we just
finish our bean and cheese did yeah we
did oh how can you okay so now we're
into the Thanksgiving dinner portion
which is always a class but we're gonna
start with a caramelized onions
caramelized onions I love those okay
cooked mushrooms I had to grow into love
of mushroom at first I was like no
you're eating fungus there's nothing
wrong
jelly turkey like you know turkey on
Thanksgiving yes exactly just like mom
used to make
and honey ham like the ham you would
have at Thanksgiving is yes
too slow
yeah you got slapped to him a little bit
makes a few good sounds like something
else
mashed potatoes oh yes you had a big
spoon over there Oh cornbread stuffing
the rice it's like a wedding Oh what
will area almost halfway the guy the
last thing on top of your Thanksgiving
is spinach I didn't know what to put
okay I wanted something green we're
going into like an Italian sandwich
territory salami pepperoni next yes we
have ham again making another debut
appearance that was I think honey bass
different yeah that's a layer 50 oh
that's 15 that's 15
oh we're halfway there yeah yeah I'm
pretty tired to you I'll take a break
yes yeah all right we're gonna make a
drink oh yeah okay so I'm gonna make
some layered drinks oh yes this is a 100
layer dip so I thought it could be fun
do some like blended stuff
so take some frozen mangoes all right
time to blend
so first there it's mango oh yeah okay
what's next we're no more berries next
texture
hey looks so good oh that's cool alright
that's layer number two last one we're
gonna go for a white banana looking
there coconut banana it's like almost
like ice cream oh wow
pretty sure people call that an ice
cream that is a three layer drink for
you and for me so pretty
all right here we go Nancy straws you're
scared
the mango is amazing pulled in enough
everything I'm trying refresh I feel
revived alright well we're gonna get
back to it
50 more layers to go we're gonna
continue where we left off yes finishing
the Italian sandwich suctioned what do
we have next three cheese and you
explain what these cheese's they're
Havarti so we're gonna party with
Havarti Colby jack and pepper jack next
we'll have a sliced black olives
we have a layer of red onions and a
layer of white onions onions have layers
yes
just like our ogres yep universe I love
track what are you doing
MS whoop okay you're much better than I
am basil jalapeno
that's not jalapenos jalapeno spicy
stuff no I can't handle spicy for the
life
8:2 flaming hot cheetos and they start
sweaty no it's not working the diced
green Chili's fried stuff oh yes onions
in French fries here we go tastes good
now we're onto our buffalo chicken dip
ah yes so we have Q tea party chips
followed by more of the color orange
great yes that's the Buffalo it's orange
dude that was a bit of a stretch it will
taste good after that we got pulled pork
yes get in there rotisserie chickens
there's a different type of chicken than
the chicken we put in earlier yes it's
different
history style and now it's blue cheese
and celery this is the weight there was
no buffalo sauce in this whole orange
the orange dude so now we are loaded
chili we're gonna start with a Mexican
cheese blend Oh
in an Italian cheese blend then Swiss
and cheddar okay do you have a giant
spoon
oh there you go it is a lot of chili
that's amazing
chili has no chill we're trying to do
thin layers yeah we're getting close to
the top the math may have may or may not
have been a little maybe we got a little
gung-ho at the top looks like finish
strong I will do the spread I'm
spreading for this challenge God my buns
can't be stopped they're wonderful so
now we are on to the stuff my mom
wouldn't buy for me as a kid that looks
good together you want to explain that
one
it's self-explanatory let's just put the
Mara not far so what's our first thing
with your fried onion onion rings oh I
love pimento yeah veggie cream cheese
there was some spinach artichoke dip in
there too more dissatisfying it's a big
blue all the things you just weren't
allowed to have I mean I would want that
store but just my mom's like no that's
not healthy it's not good for you I mean
you're wrong
this is marscapone okay so getting
really intense with the tips right now I
think it's good cream cheese even more
more white spread serious white spreads
I think that's enough
oh no that's here we go are we done with
the white spreads that's good white
spread I'm tapped we are next onto the
bruschetta spread okay so did you know
you weren't allowed to have four shut up
no chives I love chives oh that's pretty
now blue tortilla chips
nice big corner there what it's these
are fried onion yeah they're different
they're not like the chip they're actual
onion actual fried onions or last all
right it's baked potato section what do
we got right now let's change up the
color a little let's do the bacon oh
this all needs to call scallions eggs
sure hey no salad okay good
old-fashioned American orange cheese
unnatural beautiful and then not the
yellow one but the white one too
and then we're gonna put in some nacho
cheese yep that's pretty cool all right
it's like soaking into I know the cheese
is like soaking in okay so I have our
last ingredients everybody's probably
wondering by now like where is the block
don't worry we have it under control
with classic where we have tortilla
chips one is a ranch flavored nicely
done maybe we should have crushed Oh a
bit that's good hold it just like soaks
up the keys that's great sour cream sour
cream oh boy here we go again with the
white yeah it's a lot of weight at the
top it's okay all right peak oh heck
yeah what the Supreme Champion the one
we all came here there you go yeah four
she's beauty and she's grace Wow we'd
actually like filled up great level how
did this happen I don't know how did you
do this good you're a magician
your expedition put that on really
didn't it
okay finishing touches or just add some
cheddar that doesn't count
this wasn't counted so it's still nice a
little garnish garnish and the final
touch layer 100 parsley 100 whoa that is
it 100 layer dip beautiful I'm gonna go
make some giant chips to be with this oh
yeah our giant we call Shrek yep Shrek
see you back in here with some giant
chips so this
it's a giant flour tortilla the ones
used like roll burritos and they like
cut them into a like triangle and then
just spray with some oil love and bake
it until it's crispy but I ain't that oh
this is just a shovel okay okay cool
yeah you can try to dip a chip into it I
think it'll probably break you can try
and if it breaks I'll bail you out with
the with the shovel that's what this is
here for I'm like nervous the guest of
honor please as you will oh oh
yep there you go where did it go oh the
little indents oh I felt that
yeah there you go whoa all right I'll
put it place it on your chip here's you
have a fork I've got I just yep okay
we're gonna put it down this is like a
full plate of nachos
you know one scoop I see some corn nuts
[Music]
oh yeah well you can remember the one we
went through all all right well I think
this is a two-hander Cheers every time
you bite into it it's different
Oh past even my wildest dreams I don't
like an entire egg this is the joy of
the one like a treasure trove
I keep eating and you keep discovering
you're thinking the treasure is the
friends we've made along the way can you
finish this no well going through a lot
of food today yeah we did
don't want it to go to waste I have
hundreds of employees really hungry
thank you for joining us thank you
yeah great co-host made this possible
thank you Shrek we'll see you guys next
time
and we're gonna feed a lot of hungry
people peace out guys bye
[Music]
there are 110 pepperoni slices on this
pizza Oh workout
welcome back to making a big the show
where I make giant food for my friends
and special guests today I've invited in
Hannah Williams she's one of our
earliest tasty producers and makes
really fun and awesome videos with her
family on mom in progress let's go meet
her and see what she wants to eat today
how's it going good how are you good for
the people that don't know you what do
you do we better no I'm just kidding I
do a show on BuzzFeed called mom in
progress it stars my family it's like a
family vlogging show a lot of it is
giving the kids a little bit of control
and just seeing what happens like I let
the kids Mule plan our week which I feel
like in hindsight I should not have
given them seven full days it was just
junk but I was very proud that we
completed it and I stuck to my word
sounds like you guys do a lot of stuff
around food I'd love to make a giant
food for you today is there anything
that you have in mind that you'd like me
to make it from you how would you feel
about doing something for the kids oh
yeah that's awesome
yeah I know for a fact that if they were
to be presented with a giant pizza their
hats would probably explode okay so I've
made a giant pizza episode it wasn't a
whole pizza it was a three-foot slice
and to be honest like I don't think it
was as big as I could have liked I was
like kind of proud of it but I think
that there are ways that we can make the
pizza a lot bigger than the video that
I've made so bigger than three feet I
don't know how you're gonna pin it in an
oven we might have to go find another
oven if you maybe want to ask Wyatt and
Jackson what their favorite toppings are
I want to customize it so they get like
the pizza of their dreams all right
let's do it break for the kids so we are
at this place called Big Momma's in
Papa's pizzeria they make this giant 54
inch pizza they've got this huge oven
and I think they're a great fit to make
this giant piece of her white and
Jackson I spoke with the owner his
name's Tito super cool and he agreed to
let me come in try and make the giant
Pisa with him I'm very excited to make
this so let's go check
[Music]
how's it going Tico good good view for
the apron and the shirt it looks really
cool tell me about the pizza we're gonna
make today so what we got here is the
giant Sicilian is 54 by 54 inches weighs
about 50 pounds so you got 40 pounds of
dough about 5 pounds of cheese 5 pounds
of sauce it's actually the Guinness Book
of Records for the largest deliverable
pizza
really Wow what is this this is the
scream that the pizza is gonna go on I
was like that the pan yeah exactly at
home my pan is like this isn't this way
what's the first thing that we got the
first thing we got to make the dough
okay so let's go over here let's go
going so I see a very large mixer what
do we do how do we make this one out so
we got to get the flour okay so open
this bag up and I see that this has your
guyses pizzeria on yeah custom blend
this is custom okay it's a secret flour
play so we're gonna pour this in okay
you know how to tell me at least some of
the greens in here no I mean there's
your difficult yeast flour and sugar
okay and a few other low ingredients
special something yeah something special
I like that oh this is heavy
dump that in there Wow don't delegate
perfect football now we got to get the
bucket of ice and water ice some water
okay why do you use ice to keep it fresh
you gotta make sure it's the right
amount to get a right to the lion second
amount yeah and we're gonna add some
water to it this is probably another one
25 30 pounds of water but yeah ice is a
workout to make this pizza is not easy
got really good in you want to dump it
in there I gotta do some work I don't
want all right Wow that's a fact just
expect amount wow that's crazy
diners press Start yeah thank you this
will take about 25 to 30 minutes okay
yeah cuz the ice - yeah that's really
cool
I worked eco alright now we got the
dough it's ready to go okay this is
where we open the pizza so you want to
get some flour on it so there's a stick
some on the table so it doesn't get
stuck oh okay so I can try it yeah oh
sorry
don't worry oh god I'm so sorry alright
so now we're gonna bring the dough all
right well how many pounds our dough is
that this is 40 pounds 40 pounds of
dough Wow ready yeah
nice and what do you mean by opening the
dough so we're gonna have to slowly
start pushing it to get it closer to the
size of the pizza so you want to just
push like that kind of like massaging it
are you good at giving massages no but I
love receiving are you trying to go from
inside out where do you start
yeah you wanna yeah nope great alright
so what we're gonna do get our hands
down under yeah like this pretty much
okay hold it like this okay we're gonna
take it over onto that's right so what
you can do if you get it to one edge
okay you wanna wrap it wrap it around
yeah okay stretch it this way oh yeah
from the side sides
yeah stretch it more like that it's
perfect yeah
[Music]
that's pretty stretched out right yes
looking good ready I was okay here yeah
perfect oh wow perfect
he said perfect thank you all right what
is the next step next thing we gotta
poke holes in it whoa what does that
mean this is like a torture device okay
what is the process like so you just
gotta roll up and down so I try it looks
like grant Packers perfect perfect all
right now we got the pizza sauce okay Oh
interesting so I would usually think
that a pizza this big would need a lot
but I guess you found the right balance
of songs across okay so what we're gonna
do about this we're gonna spread it
throughout the dough and then we'll just
spread it out and the gloves on okay
cool you want to put some I can try
start with the edges okay then we'll
work our way in oh boy there you go oh
is that okay yeah there's no right or
wrong you just want to get it around
there's no straight on I like Willis guy
[Music]
we got our gloves what I wanna do is
just spread it out nice and nice and
evenly kind of like this axe right
just gotta leave a little crust there
okay got it
this is the focus of the pump right your
hands all in there kinda feels like when
you know finger paint that's like yeah
exactly how do you guys develop this
pizza it started with the Big Mama pizza
which is a 28-inch uh-huh and then we
went okay we gotta do something more
unique then we noticed that the size of
the oven is about 55 inches so we're I
can't let's see how far we can push this
button were you we're just bored what
now you're like oh he was the biggest
he's like it's something unique
something that kids love it's more
easier when you're catering instead of
getting like 10 15 different pizzas you
just got one huge one this looks perfect
yeah why don't we go through most of
everything covered all right we're extra
is the cheese it's a lot of cheese yeah
it's a mixture of mozzarella cheese and
provolone cheese Parmesan cheese Wow yes
we're gonna do the same thing with the
pizza sauce we're gonna grab it spread
it out throughout like this just so
we're going all around the edges oh boy
here we go
perfect I'm all shaky don't worry about
it cuz I have to be perfect we're gonna
spread it out anyway
we'll just grab it in your hands okay
yeah we'll grab it just sprinkle it huh
and how much cheese is this this is five
pounds five pounds of cheese okay the
same thing we're kind of spreading it
out making it even is that good yeah how
much do you guys get this requested to
be made we do about seven a month I
would say it's a lot of work yeah
we also have a challenge for this so
it's eight people you have two hours to
finish it who out the whole thing the
whole thing and you get a thousand
dollars how many people have finished it
we've had a few people do it actually in
December the record was for people in 34
minutes I believe the job cavemen were
these giants perfect that looks great
this is good yep nice all right so what
toppings are we doing so the kids
there's this end of a little video
what's your favorite food Jackson my
history what's ours word cheese pizza
Wyatt enough no I saw that so I was
maybe thinking because this is a square
would it be possible to almost like have
four quadrants yeah
Oh we'll do a quarter cheese quarter
pepper olives
that's great perfect all right so we got
the ingredients we got the pepperoni
olives and the sliced ham yeah which
speaking of which sliced hands I
remember when I first started working
the restaurant I didn't know how to cut
that well okay so I'll cut like really
slow so I'll be just you know taking my
time making sure everything is okay and
then my boss will come by or cover in
just
so he thought it was a professional
cutter that didn't work of course yeah
he was like this Tico's my merry god
yeah
maybe let start with the pepperoni King
is there like a strategy for how to
arrange it at least every slice to have
two slices I like they're only for sure
and each one is about maybe a quarter
inch apart
exactly okay I've seen a lot of pizzas
were like it starts out far and then
toppings become close because the cheese
sauce okay that is actually from a lot
of the cheese you put too much cheese it
starts melting so it moves and so not
only are you thinking about how much
sauce you put how much she's affects the
way the top exact that's that's a big
brain level that's 3,000 IQ how many
calories do you think this entire point
is over a thousand for sure yeah I think
she's alone might be over a thousand so
I think I'm a little slow knows don't
worry if you don't yeah your look her
face started all those that'd be great
yeah I think by the time you finished to
have home we've done for this layer I'm
just gonna make a ring somewhere all
this oh yeah make it I like I like the
way this guy talks oh he beat me I can't
even finish this before he's there four
five six seven eight nine
there are 110 pepperoni slices on this
pizza naturally at its corner and that's
just a quarter the whole thing would
have had 440 pepperoni slices what is
the next step okay talk to me about how
do you bake a 50 pound a 54 inch slice
pizza how does that different than a
just a normal slice well it takes much
longer and instead of just being able to
turn it around in the oven we're gonna
have to take it completely out turn
around and put it back in
oh my god we won't grab this side I'll
grab this side let's do so oh wow this
is amazing
there you go Oh so it like kind of hangs
about a hang up the oven technically
isn't big enough we could take it out oh
yeah look at that it's like a whole
field it um pizza like farm of ham here
you got a barb of Olives we got the city
of pepperoni back there this is really
good okay so this cooks for how long oh
we're giving it about 15 minutes okay
we'll turn it around all right well I'll
get to see you guys in 15 minutes okay
so now we're gonna take it out try to
cook the other quarter of it you got it
Oh made it on this table here is so
heavy this way and we'll put this side
in
I'm up Yeti yeah let's go let's go whoa
oh man this is a workout yeah I don't
know how you do it oh my god
now we're gonna do about another 15 15
15 minutes huh we'll turn into another
cool and check it yeah all right well
cool
all right turn number two
yeah looks amazing yeah I understand
what you have to cook it a bit at a time
yeah we'll get this side in perfect whoa
Oh workout huh to work so I put some oil
on the crust uh-huh to keep it yeah
Bernie something this large you never
know right let's go yeah here we go
we're pros now yeah cool 15 minutes
we'll be back because box oh nice
oh my god okay guys are you saying to
here so we're gonna have to take it out
and then slide it off ultra directly
okay so this is like the toughest part
right this is yeah all right I won't
tell you that's got there's got this
last one this is slowly out again yeah
you got it yeah so we're gonna just tilt
it a little bit until we get the edge
some room we can grab on from the edge
okay that's a good job
nice work that was that was crazy let's
go inside
Wow so we delivered this on top of our
smart car got a custom-made layup like
when you're going on a ski trip and
you're like wrapping the back yeah you
only do that out let's do it all right I
got it
let's go feel like I'm in a Mario Party
in end up in shoulder press all right
nice
yep okay well no jump today yeah no
don't eat it goes in jail okay
driving this back to the BuzzFeed
headquarters not at all right school I
will meet you there
sounds good all right you're welcome all
righty
oh nice we're back at BuzzFeed
Thank You Tico for driving it all the
way over I'm very excited to have the
kids try it out thank you had fun thank
you for letting in their kitchen thank
you um but yeah I'm very excited no
peeking I'm okay cover your eyes on the
count of three guys I want you guys to
open eyes ready one two three
take a look you guys want to see the
inside yeah all right I'll take the lid
off this is my best day ever
yeah you guys guess how many pounds this
entire pizzas a hundred millions very
close how many people do you think it
would take to finish it
this is gonna finish this entire piece
hey Wyatt would slice do you want oh
you're gonna make me reach all the way
over there okay you see why cars can I
have a cheese of course you can have
change pizza here you go mr. Jackson
thank you hold on up next to your face
let me see that is longer than your face
this is the best pizza you've ever had
this is better than new
[Music]
[Music]
Wow amazing you've got some tomato sauce
turn you up well thank you for coming
keep up the good work in school okay
listen to your mom I love you guys so
much I know how much you love peace well
this is it that's that that is it okay
sorry I'll do that [ __ ] well this is it
that was the season finale for a season
two of tasties making a big I hope you
guys had as much fun as me thank you for
all the support so far your ideas are
always appreciated so keep sending them
keep them coming we always are making
great and awesome things for awesome
people until next time
[Music]